The spirit of man has awakened.
The soul of man has gone forth.
Grant us the wisdom and the vision to comprehend the greatness of man's spirit...
...that suffers and endures so hugely for a goal beyond his own brief span.
We are all of us children of Earth,...
...grant us that simple knowledge.
If our brothers are oppressed, then we are oppressed.
If they hunger, we hunger.
If their freedom is taken away, our freedom is not secure.
Grant us a common faith, that man shall know bread and peace;...
...that he shall know justice and righteousness, freedom and security,...
...an equal opportunity, and an equal chance to do his best,...
...not only in our own lands, but throughout the world.
And in that faith let us march,...
...march toward the clean world our hands can make.
Amen.